naturally uncle mumtaz electronic dragon
come around asking Michael is like a
vegetable adapting with parity hustle my
my name is Jerry Saba [ __ ] I've
been telling you talk about I'll triple
together the pedigree to being an
especial a penalty putting the work that
I'm doing are the moving furniture
there's so much good you know one could
argue that they don't like fake news I
could argue is the world better two or
three old white dudes dictate the entire
conversation and media and where we go
there's a pro and con to all this all
the people that find love and great
relationships that never would have
because of this technology all the
people that are on this trip right now
that can FaceTime their family and have
that connection that we could have never
done before this is a net positive the
world has never been better yet we
continue to look at the negatives it's
what happens it's what happens as we get
older but the technology changes and the
social changes have just begun the
upside is enormous enormous one could
say virtual reality sounds scary and not
fun I could argue like what's wrong with
living your life and then living in a
nicer place and lowering the cost of
where we live because that becomes
commoditized and live healthier and you
know who's gonna be able to balance
getting off of it we're living in a
virtual reality world now there are
people that spend 7 8 12 13 14 hours of
their day in a screen now this is the
way it is and so either we can cry about
it and put our head in the sand and
think it's a negative or we can grab it
and understand all the great changes my
brother left my business because he has
Crohn's disease right
there's been no way that I could impact
the change in that disease the way I am
now because of these devices and
technologies 10 or 15 or 20 years ago
the impact was this big compared to this
big because of the amplification and the
messaging that can be done and so you as
an individual person here are going to
decide that all of this is a negative or
all of this is a positive I've chosen
this to be a massive positive it is good
there's so much opportunity there's so
many great things we're doing for so
many people and if you look at the data
if you like data the world is better
than it's ever been across the board
right now what we have to do is make
this micro and bring it home I am so
packed in it for everybody to understand
that before you critique or judge the
generations below you take a look under
the hood and really understand it go
look at studies like the average 14 year
old girl 20 years ago
claimed to have 1.4 best friends and now
claims to have six that because if you
didn't have the serendipity of being in
a school where people were nice to you
and maybe you didn't have any outlet and
you were going to get bullied you now
can go online and find your actual
friends and spend time with so I think
we spend a lot of time on the negative
and we don't talk about the positive
what I would implore you to do is think
about the benefits of positive versus
negative I would implore you especially
if you care if it's underneath you to
start getting on the offense around
things like self-esteem because that's
where it comes from instead of looking
at the other way yep definitely put your
device back yes or say you're home
get someone ours yeah yep
yeah I'm just curious about your family
dynamics
yes you all have phones we we we run the
get to a couple things we run the gamut
first and foremost I think we all know
this there's a couple places I'm talking
in general terms if you've noticed like
to me the least interesting thing in the
world is to tell people how to parent
their children right I mean there's so
many individual context here in this
room everybody's got their own dynamics
I think it's a lazy and convenient thing
now here's what I believe I will
there's a great Russian saying we all
kind of shortcut of mini I believe
everything is best when it's balanced
anything you know balance is great but I
also think you have to understand so
many variables and I think that
therapists if you look at the history of
the feedback of therapists over the last
hundred years the consensus has been
wrong plenty of times because therapists
are collectively poor at predicting what
happens next
as our most people we make a lot of
decisions without understanding what
happens next and so you know my family
first of all I'm a workaholic Monday
through Friday at least see my family
that's just true so on the weekends it's
extreme the other way we take seven
weeks vacation all in phone locked up
because I'm playing such extreme some
I'm so politically not correct
on the current state of parenting on
just the framework of what where I am
with them Monday through Friday let
alone am i sitting there with a phone or
not going dinnertime right here's my big
thing parents always think they're
protecting kids the amount of parents
over the last 20 years who took their
kids away from making 15 million dollars
a year being an esports superstar who's
now making 81 thousand dollars a year in
middle management and what to kill
himself is enormous so so what what I
you know there's been more parenting
books written in the last seven years
than prior of the beginning of mankind
to those seven years ago America is very
good at one very interesting thing
telling people and selling on fear and
telling them what they're not good at
and the current state of parenting has
completely gone into that direction I
have no interest in the collective you
know current politically correct POV on
parenting what I'm interested in is
reverse engineering my kids I don't need
them to be entrepreneurs
I don't care what they want to do I just
want to pay attention to their behavior
at scale and reverse engineer that and
instill so much self esteem into them
that they're borderline delirious
because that is the drug that stops them
from the dumb [ __ ] that we all fear but
no 8th place trophies because that [ __ ]
has [ __ ] us up
like thank you
education acknowledged yeah but a lot of
money I was I was a bad student let's
remember the famous dropped out of
college 98% of them not me but 98% of
them are dropping out of Stanford and
Harvard you know like the whole dropped
out of college thing has been very
romanticized these are really some
hearts individual value of formalism I
don't I do not I'm super comfortable so
first of all I speak at all these top
universities I'm teaching a class at
Stanford this and that the lack of
practicality that is being taught in our
universities the reality the world is
staggering it's a bigger version of what
I said here with the kids what world do
you think they're going to live in now
if you want to do a certain profession
I'm understand the practicality of
having to own a diplomas that gives you
the aback I spent a lot of my time in
the business entrepreneurial world
there's zero mapping for that the MBA or
the business school mapping to the
reality success has been completely
blown out the water and the other thing
that we don't talk enough about is how
this debt destroys individuals like you
don't get out of it sometimes until
their 40s in a proper way so and not
well here's where I'm going I think the
thing that has not been talked about
that it's probably more interesting than
things I just said is colleges are built
on brand like at the biggest things
they're doing right now is they're
cleaning these online courses that are
diluting their brand Penn and Stanford
and Harvard have these online courses
and if you look at the way the people
that are taking them are positioning
their their certification from these
courses they're not giving it the proper
they're just saying I want to Harvard
and so I think the biggest universities
in the world right now for a short term
income because they're getting scale of
$18,000 online courses that are 4 weeks
and they're bringing in revenue are
actually diluting their brand so much
and I don't think that Harvard and
Stanford actually understand that
they're only trading on brand only
because the education has been
commoditized because the professor's
have that and they're putting out their
content online for free you can like see
it for free when they're giving a TED
talk or doing for interviews so the
actual education the words what I've
been up there that's commoditized that's
zero the only thing these big
universities are working on is brand
equity because you grew up believing in
it so you're forcing your kids to
believe in it that's very close to the
newspaper revenue model of collapsing so
I think they only have 30 to 40 years
left
[Music]
[Music]
you don't forget don't forget lost in
history is like when we definitely felt
like you know what should we just sell
Boehner for a million dollars we had
that discussion you were out and I was
like I don't know like kid aha you know
like it was there you know I wish
[ __ ] dailyvee was there for that
scene before that speech uh techstars
you know that'd be fun even look at so
like I mean I think you know I think
there's a million things to go through
and we you know it's always fun to I
think this is a perfect example of like
not my first rodeo right isn't it fun
for you to like have all that context
right mm-hmm
the ability for us to do a commercial a
two-minute like I am now I'm also
creating this whole Facebook commercial
thing I think we're going to be able to
do some really good deals where boy and
he's doing it for the 7 location piece
of shops and we send stuff on and make a
two-minute video for Facebook that's why
they're going to want to do it every
single day people should wake up open
explore feature in Twitter look at the
hashtags click the trending hashtag and
make a piece of content
that if this was defined more time I
would be doing that every two hours it
is an absolute way to build up on
Twitter numbers really pay attention as
much Twitter which is written and
snapchat are rolling out of it but human
looking at my own dynamics when I when I
leverage a trending hashtag is this
exponential and I'm on this real kick
for this video this is the positivity
video this one when I think about our
capabilities to eliminate each other
I'm being serious I know it's kind of a
weird place to go but like the fascial
we're still here we are hard-wired in a
way that allows us to protect each other
in a net game yet the mainstream media
and the way we hear all you hear is
negativity all that mainstream media
does is tell us about the point zero
zero zero one percent worst of us I
think we as humans are going to have
some level of a sense of responsibility
that if you're a good place it might be
good to tweet or Instagram or snapchat
about that versus what we default into
which is no people's Twitter feeds that
are basically every seven or ten days
when they're complaining about an
airline or venting about work like the
volume of negativity is just way too
high in reality of what's going on every
Empire Falls when the silent majority of
happy isn't loud enough and they lose
the branding we love the third wall you
rock that third wall no I just pulled up
where do I go
all right right right to the left here
right for that first building like right
by the baseball stadium Sports Complex
do I go towards the the football field
the field house let me go see Alvin
Kamara right now beasts some bunch of
you watching this right now he's about
to be your favorite football player so
craziness like watch it watch us in a
year right you see you go this
is there something Gary real pleasure
how are you give me real good real good
how you feeling you didn't look it is
look it is Nikki she's about the role of
that way too if they're just a mix of
people working out here like it's
football right
very nice real nice to meet you don't
freak out no I'm believe I'm comfortable
I love it man I [ __ ] love team sport
man oh god I wish I was dramatically
faster and dramatically stronger ah ha
I'd give up all the business riches to
come you know what is the competition
that ships us that's the reason I love
business so much if I can replicate it a
little bit cuz I'm trying to put bucking
I'm trying to put people out of [ __ ]
business you know you were there
definitely when I was like listen to me
[ __ ] you can win or you can feel
tough like or you're going to lose one
of them that's the problem that's the
problem when you're doing sports and
music it's just not a lot in the middle
so what's on your mind like what's
important to you anything like well how
do you thinking or just focused on right
you still got a black can we change this
logo
your [ __ ] space it's you got a pretty
face like stare
well Phyllis basement thing to do is
continue to ingest roldo take you to a
chest logo funny how I feel about gyms
now now that I actually work out I like
it how you can do some pull-ups show me
I want to see your [ __ ] okay good here
I'll give you the boss I want to see how
many tyke it is at six that's good
goes high I'm impressed
get that head baby one more let's go
that's going to be some good student
[ __ ] fortify the first area marking oh
my god Alvin Tyler should be dead I hit
my car in New York City it should be
dead
straight up some dead [ __ ] serious I
got a good idea I'm going to go face to
fly and
and make people try to get Alvin to go
on 13 missile are its what is that
[ __ ] bird
yo yo yo Instagram alright football fans
time to make your speed your case for
the best running back in the [ __ ]
draft Alvin Wong right who wants Alvin
on their team show me tell Alvin what
team you need to be dragged by Oscar
first the jet the jet
what up Shannon legendary there let's
see one of these is about to be real
happy one of you is about to buy a
jersey of this man
okay there's Ravens first big fan yes
mister that was let me save that one
sure might pick the pack by the way I
think the Packers actually yeah that
could be interesting
defensively the oak Evan Russia Cairo
Cairo if you guys drop this man could be
the greatest day of your life
got the superstar hall-of-famer get
ready
tell him he's guys imagine imagine if
your career was predicated on to random
days in Indianapolis where like millions
of dollars one stake for a hundredth of
a second
hey Rose imagine you had a right code
for an hour and that no predicted if you
were going to be good or I had 40
minutes four minutes on the liquor store
floor and how much wine I sold they
predicted my whole career on that crazy
anyway I thought albums got to get to
work
he's still in a dungeon that's why he's
here that's why his profile so all-black
this guy I talked to you guys like press
with the chin up huh
and they were they were [ __ ] one
till you try to do improper come on you
know starting boxing and near that a
year and a half yeah when Jordans done
and doing three years of boxing I'm
going to box every morning I'm into
boxing I'm gonna go in the ring at 45 a
Nazi rock out oh how do you think about
it I wouldn't dream of it yeah well it's
like right there right right no no I
felt awful and from the get you like
this what I want to do yeah Gate buzzes
hi Corey came out and I was good cause I
could kick the ball over the fence come
from another angle get the ball for the
ball I jump over it to get it everything
and I mean I was small bedroom mm-hmm my
mother in trust the process enhances to
me look yeah if we gonna get hurt yeah
yeah so my grandmother she snuffed me on
the field when she dropped my mud off at
work so like he got those clothes on he
brought that from like Walmart or
something my mama go to Walmart and
clothes and bring me the practice and
change me up back in those clothes
I love that you should call you see my
okay I know exactly you know what's so
funny I was just reading about that
Suzie vert up in Philly yeah how his mom
wouldn't let it like how nobody believed
him as grandma got him that Mike Jones
album and she's like keep going keep
going
you need somebody you gotta have
somebody you know ya watchin that to 12
month a year sport why these kids play
longer you know Harry Caray Swiss mom
take they're yours oh thank you man I
appreciate the like for everything you
do Thank You Man
you're on your [ __ ] don't you example I
just came to see Alvin and I'm headed
back to New York in a second of it yeah
thanks coming down horse lamp I present
here over stair academic unit fantastic
that's how you commanded to come back
I'm glad you didn't look man I just know
I'm in great shape thank you real
pleasure singing I love it thank you
of course thanks my lovely man takes for
an object when I talk to you soon
continued success here bet your iPhone
yeah there you go
I'm going to get you 25 actually he'll
[ __ ] around eclipses like Randy will
be in the middle of work all right Burt
really you don't know where I want you
to [ __ ] you polite it's like just
like comma a press away when we
obviously like Michael B no prison well
that's exactly right y'all ran through
it for me being proud of it did you guys
hear that they're doing the fans for the
first time but they can't say [ __ ]
that's gonna be the weirdest [ __ ]
there's gonna be like don't be welcome
there should be like a thousand fans
watching but they can't say a word look
at this family yeah the whole thing a
weird lot of times actually happens in
the comments section around the creative
where then we can go in and business
develop and we could we start with
leverage because people reaching out to
us I want to be involved with this is an
extraordinarily big difference between
the way marketing is the number the last
70 years where we as marketers and
business people sit in a silo and try to
create the business development instead
of letting the lead creative become the
platform that creates those
opportunities and for my personal brand
and sort of start up some working with
so much of the extension of campaigns
have happened in the comments section of
the creative once deployed
[Music]
la stand up 6 p.m. Wednesday 15 of you
right because I'm taking offense 15 of
you are going to be able to be part of
something remarkable intimate access I
got to do this crazy [ __ ] thing and
I'm going to do a random contest for 15
of you to come and join and be a part of
it so Wednesday 6 p.m.
[ __ ] call out sick cancel your
vacation a lot of your mother
one thing 6 p.m. 15 of you I'll do
something on Monday or Tuesday in
Instagram as a contest and then I asked
how I'm going to pick my 15 see you then
Wednesday 6 p.m. next week Los Angeles
you got them working coach is a very
expensive I mean how is he I mean he
always wants to but I really just the
way he talks about you I'm just so
thankful and grateful thank you so much
I love the way you do it like all now
that I'm learning this game all these
fancy guys selling on [ __ ] 90%
[ __ ] nothing that's going to make
you real money and real happiness on the
field draw right so we just appreciate
it though he's been catered uh okay man
and you know we go hardcore you know you
are doing them really right yeah I
appreciate it if I can it'll be a help
to you let me know okay okay thank you
letting out I want to simulate you all
go move back let's kick ass alright good
luck on everything presume you ever need
me Oh
yes you would laugh is that right yes of
course no problem anyone
thank you for my big pleasure to be okay
thank you very much Anna transforming
into airport Gary look at that guy's
kick
well jet board results - overall you can
do it ahsoka thank you thank you very
much my pleasure thank you my friend
thank you thank you
warm out how tomorrow Vandercook taught
me how to pack thanks mom for packing me
all the time
fair poor Gary what places I think it's
a phone call I'm like so like so wired
for action like Coco what [ __ ]
all right give me the video
yeah great week
I should totally rest me you know it's
so you know son here you look so weird
this was such a rough week yet I was
like tired you know because I wasn't
tired because it was a rest place it
wasn't that late like every day people
don't love seeing the video anything
that's going to go vaccination
[Music]
when I turn 3d rocks and that dude right
there
[Music]
you
[Music]